[Music]
yeah you know podcasting is super fun
but you know it's a job - yeah and I
knew going in I wasn't one of those
peoples like oh I'm just gonna do it
like right my research I knew but I
thought I'm the type of person would I
feel I need to do I would write but then
I was just kind of like for me with the
setup that I had it wasn't really giving
me the return in terms of the audience
and all the things and it would it was
gonna take even more work to build my
energy well you're doing like a million
things right so I was like I can't even
keep track of all like you're on TV your
dad I mean what what what's like top of
mind right now like what do I mean you
got the TV show right on own so yeah I
host a show on own I've been hosting
since I stopped boxing you know I went
on Dancing with the Stars right and that
was a while ago though that was a while
ago before I even had kids yeah I
retired in 2007 and then I did that
right afterwards and that was just a
strategic move you know in terms of just
opening myself to an audience right and
how was that it was crazy yeah yeah it's
a lot of work right like the people that
do well train really hard and you almost
I mean what you were like third or
something like that right yeah everybody
trains hard you have to in order to just
get out there and perform but I think
that um you know me being an athlete it
wasn't as hard physically as it was for
everyone else for a lot of but it's
physically hard for me it was more
mental because working with a partner
when you're used to just going out there
I'm used to going in a ring like I'm
gonna win this finite period it's just
me yeah but I had to rely on my partner
dance with the partner then sometimes we
weren't always getting along but you
don't know how show that on on camera so
it's just like ah you know what I want
to get to the end so you know I did so
it was it was worth it it was fun how
did the boxing experience and training
inform how you approach dance I approach
pretty much everything the same way I
was saying and it's just like I go I
first have to assess the situation you
know what's it gonna take of me because
I'm one of those people that feels like
I can pretty much do anything that I
want to do so first I had to say okay do
I really want to do this you know I
didn't at first I was just like I don't
want to do this no and then I thought
about actually this could be a really
good platform so I had to get my
strategic line and then
I realized oh I need to do this then I
was like okay I want to do this and I
assess how much work I thought it was
gonna take and I just kind of put it in
you know this is like I like to like for
fighting for example I know there's an
in goal and I know I have whether
there's an eight week or a ten week
training camp mm-hmm for these eight to
ten weeks I'm gonna go hard as hell you
know and then there's an end so with
dancing I kind of looked at it that way
okay how long do I need to do this you
know this is what's gonna come at the
end and then you know if it's open-ended
it's like oh yeah me yeah but I think
coming from boxing it would seem to me
there's a lot of I mean they're very
different but there's still some
similarities like its footwork its
repetitive motions it's kind of you know
there's a sort of get there's a dance to
boxing as well right like I feel like
boxing is probably well-suited for
making that kind of switch no I mean
when you have to really narrow it down
to the pros and the cons and what you're
bringing into it you know because
everyone's you know that that comes from
whether you're an actor or a singer or a
performer like I can look at the
performers and be like that's not fair
they're performers like this is nothing
for them whereas a boxer then someone
who was an actress would say oh no but
you have the footwork but it's totally
different is so different yeah like I've
seen other boxers going there and they
didn't necessarily do as well uh-huh you
know what I mean so it takes so much
more than that yeah why do you think you
got all the way to near the end then
versus the other but I think it was a
multitude of things I think for one the
audience and has to like you the judges
you know cuz the audience votes the
judges vote and you have to do well so I
think that for me I brought a different
energy than most because for one I'm not
the average size I'm a big girl I'm
strong physically a lot of muscle you
know I'm moving in and out but I was out
there doing my thing whereas in the
dance world you know they're very strict
not for Dancing with the Stars but in
the real dance world right it's like you
have to be a certain size you have to be
petite you have to be shorter than the
man you know all these different things
and I didn't really fit any of that but
I kind of made it my own and came out
there and just do my thing so I think
that it's really just the feeling that
people get when they see
you and then they want to get behind you
and it's like you know right I mean
that's my take on it I mean there's like
40 million people that watch that show
right I mean since I had to be kind of a
whirlwind crazy I mean in terms of like
a strategic trajectory of saying okay
I'm leaving boxing and now I want to set
myself up for something else like I mean
you certainly you know you succeeded in
introducing yourself to America in a
different way it was it where I assume
it worked
yeah well I posing right right now at
that I'm gonna knock him out no I'm glad
no it was fun because when I went into
boxing you know I felt like I had to
prove myself I had to prove that I was
tough I had to prove that I just want to
be a fighter I had to really find my own
lane and I had spent so much time being
serious and being a hardcore all the
time every time you saw me I was I'm not
knocking somebody out now I'm kind of
intimidating and approachable come on oh
you know yeah that's cool but wait yeah
so for me but that's not who I am that
was Who I am in the ring so I you know I
was so young too so now I kind of felt
like you know what this is gonna be fun
I'm gonna show different people
different side of myself and I was able
to introduce people who didn't even know
me or know anything about me they just
knew okay Muhammad Ali's daughter she
was an officer to see me for the first
time so it was just fun it was a fun
transition for me so yeah so now you're
doing the TV show which is kind of like
it's like a Home Makeover kind of thing
you help people you know figure their
[ __ ] out Yeah right
well homemade simple has been work it's
going into his ninth season and there's
been different hosts and I'm the host
now and when I became the host it went
from a half-hour show to an hour show
and we really get more into the stories
of individuals because these are people
who are amazing I mean like you'd have a
mom who is single but she's taken on her
sister's kids because her sister passed
away you know or something like that and
she just is like I need a place where I
can go to relax so will she want her
master bedroom made over so I'll come in
with a team and you know we'll kind of
take that that on and do it but then
there's DIY projects and I get in the
kitchen and I cook you know recipes out
of my cookbook fried alive so that's fun
for me so I've hosted a lot of shows but
I really like this show in particular
because I get to work with people
and I get to do the things that I love
you know cooking and decorating I'm not
the decorator we have a designer but I
just yeah I've always loved it
yeah it sounds like fun yeah it is fun
so I just just a couple weeks ago I went
to the premiere of what's my name
oh yeah were you there I was I figured
you probably were in LA now yeah yeah
yeah I'm friends with Billy Gerber oh
one of the producers on the movie and he
was gracious enough to give me an invite
and there were so many things about your
father that I didn't know that I learned
I mean it's it's there's a lot look
there's so much film on your dad and a
lot of documentaries and movies have
been made but this really took it back
way back and all this footage of him
when he and you just realized like man
he was so young when all of this started
can you imagine being that yeah magic I
know his first boxing match he's like 16
it's on TV right and he's almost fully
formed at that point like he figure I
think there's this conventional wisdom
that that all the trash talk kind of
started once he got big but it kind of
starts way earlier than that yeah I
think that you just caught it on camera
more I think a big but it was always
there right yeah and I was I was struck
by you know just the the beauty and the
elegance with which he lived his life
and you don't want to get into it a
little bit more but kind of just
stepping off of that you know as his
daughter you know you mentioned earlier
like everybody knows you as his daughter
right and that's like a that's like a
one of the biggest shadows you know of
all time to have to kind of live in and
I would imagine that there's great
things about that and there's also like
a lot of challenges that you probably
wish you know you could just whisk away
you know it's crazy because that is I'm
definitely always gonna be Muhammad
Ali's daughter uh-huh
but I don't feel uncomfortable with it
you know it's like I don't really feel
like I'm in his shadow even though I to
other people I probably am yeah no let
me say that again to other people I am
yeah
because I've always kind of woken up
thinking like hmm what's lately gonna do
today you know it's not like hmm I'm
Muhammad Ali's daughter what was that
gonna do right a day you know what I'm
saying so me and my father are so alike
but so different and we've always been
like people just a second head yes yeah
I'll just assume that I'm daddy's girls
and all that and I'm so not on the last
you know there's nine of us I know and
yeah you're like you're the a timeline
right yeah so we have a brother who was
adopted when you know forget how old I
was when he was adopted but I'm the
youngest of my dad's and natural
children and I'm the youngest girl and
then I'm like the feistiest yeah most
challenging one for him so what did you
guys butt heads over oh my god I always
know I do a lot of public speaking and I
and I always talk about the three times
the three big meetings that we had so I
remember okay first of all I'm not
Muslim that was big you saw how much you
watched the movie if you didn't know
before you know my whole my dad's whole
life is like based around his religion
and for me to be an 8 year old at the
time and am estimating seven or eight
and I told my dad I don't want to be
Muslim he's just like what like you know
you're not old enough to know what you
want and I was like I'm old enough to
know it's not in my heart it's not my
heart mm-hmm so what can he say yeah so
then it was kind of no he didn't like
that at all so then everything from then
on out was this happened because you're
not Muslim are you doing that because
you're not Muslim and everything's like
because I'm not Muslim yeah and I'm like
oh really so as I got older and then we
you know and I'd say for example I had
on fitted jeans like I have on now so I
could be staring at you I got those
jeans on you know men are gonna look at
your butt and they're just gonna want to
have sex with you go on this whole
tangent I'm like I don't want to hear
you talking to me that way you know
something we kind of get into it all the
time like yeah and I'm not gonna come
visit you when you come in town if
you're gonna disrespect me you know we'd
be back and forth so it was like that
then when I was 18 I moved out the house
and moved in with a boyfriend
uh-huh and it was like you're that one
over oh yeah but it was like but it
wasn't so much the you know I'm worried
about you and you're too young above a
guy was just know you're living in sin
and it was a it was a religious thing
again and I was like I'm not Muslim so
then that became an issue and I was like
wait
I pay my own bills because I I've always
I had a business when I was you know 18
at a nail salon I doubt I was supporting
myself so then I was kind of like you're
not gonna tell me what to do and then of
course in the boxing that was another
conversation right he tried to talk me
out of that yeah yeah so I mean that
makes you your father's daughter like
that that spirit that feistiness that's
fine as I said that's him too right yes
so he able to recognize yeah yeah oh
yeah at a certain point unless I'm
saying I remember when he told me not to
box you know first he tried to talk me
out of it indirectly and when he because
I kind of started in secrecy because I
was like had to figure out for myself is
this what I really want to do I
understood everything that was gonna
come with it but I was like let me get
in the gym see if I even have the talent
because I don't want to embarrass myself
I don't want to embarrass my family and
I just want to be good so I trained and
for like six months without anyone
knowing it all flood yeah it was kind of
like I'm just I was like I'm just gonna
go lose some weight workout but I knew
what our goal was so when it got around
to him and he asked me about it instead
are you in the gym and I'm like yeah I
am and it was just like well what are
you gonna do you know it's gonna be so
much attention on you so much pressure
on you my god I'm I'm ready to deal with
that I've thought that through well what
if you get knocked down in the ring and
lights are on he builds this whole scene
and you're on the canvas and everybody's
watching I was like well you've been
knocked down and what you did or you
could just say well well you know what
would you have said if somebody said
that to you document well like I didn't
even you know at the end of the day I
wasn't even trying to talk him out of
try and talk me out of it I was just
going with this flow I knew where he was
going with it and I was like just answer
I'm saying I'm gonna do what you did you
got up right and then if he got so
frustrated he finally was just like it's
not for you it's not for women it's too
hard it's not a woman sport and I just
said you know what Dad I cuz I expected
him to say something like that and I
just said you know what I understand how
you feel but this is what I'm gonna do
and I've already made my mind up so he
just had to roll yeah he came around oh
yeah yeah and he apologized
I remember one my second title and he
came to my dressing room after the fight
and he had tear he's to cry all the time
tears of joy usually but he had tears in
his eyes and I my oh god what now and he
says you know I want to apologize to you
I was wrong and I'm sorry women can
fight you can fight and then of course
he starts trying to show me how to jab
and trying to I was like now you want to
teach me something like I already got
world titles like what are you talking
about
so well let's let's
step it back a little bit I mean did you
first of all were you an athlete like in
high school not at all you didn't do
anything nope not even like basketball
volleyball nothing I was too busy being
bad at school I was always what were you
in there oh my god ditching you know I I
had a very dysfunctional childhood born
in Miami but did you did you grow you
got a high school around here I here
grew up I saw I was born in Miami
literally just was there probably not
even 30 days my dad was training for a
fight and then we flew back here so I
grew up in LA all of my life so let's go
to high school I went to multiple
multiple high schools because like I
said I was bad I went to Hamilton I went
to uni I went to Venice I went to Culver
City like I used to get yeah I got out a
couple times yeah for fighting so like I
always tell people no I was always a
fighter so I had a dysfunctional family
being that my mom and dad got divorced
my stepdad was an [ __ ] and I remember
moving from the Hancock Park area which
is adjacent to Beverly Hills where we
lived and then my mom getting remarried
so we're moving to Malibu now that was
like crushed me like to go to a whole
new place down the coast I'm talking
about 15 minutes past Pepperdine like
yeah like there's nothing going nothing
there no friends nobody so that like
broke my heart and then the whole
dysfunction started happening so I was
angry kid yeah and just trying to find
myself
and trying to always get back to LA so I
was spinning out friend's house a lot
and all that and then I always had this
tough exterior about me and I was like a
rebel without a cause and I just got
myself in trouble hanging around the
wrong crowd ditching school and then one
day I was with this young lady who
shoplifted and then it was like oh let's
go I don't pay for anything and I'm like
oh okay I have money in my pocket so I
shop lifted with her got caught got in
the system that's how I ended up in the
system and now I'm on probation yeah and
then I got in trouble again and then I
got put in juvenile hall right so I went
that was like the end of my my world
like because I was had this attitude
like oh yeah I'm gonna go to court today
and I'll be home later and then the
judge actually locked me up and I was in
juvenile hall for three months Wow yeah
I was a long time yeah and then after
juvenile hall I came out and had to go
to a group home because they were like
you know something's not right at your
house and it wasn't
my mom just really didn't know what's
going on with me she was like caught up
in her marriage and I ended up in a
group home in the program that I had to
graduate which most people don't
graduate they say you're not you're
gonna be here for at least a year and I
was like I cannot be here for you so
then I got out I graduated in six months
and then I got back on track because I'd
already went to school to learn how to
do nails and then I got my license I
moved out the house and kind of never
look back on all right so juvie was like
what were you were like 17 or 16 yeah 15
I was 15 and it was like the best thing
that ever happened to me yeah but that
was like to have your freedom take a you
know yeah to have your freedom anyway
sorry not that long yeah yeah good night
that's what I'm saying most the time
when I say that people I oh you got in
trouble your parents came and got you
was like no right and then when I got
arrested I use the name Anderson which
was my mom's name at the time because I
didn't want to say Olly and they asked
yeah so they had no one really no one
knew until well now what a Jawa to just
exam well they it started to get around
because you you see kids come through
that are like wait a minute I know her
from my school you know and then it kind
of got around right I was always you
know my file was always under the name
Anderson and I never got sentenced to
time that's the crazy thing the judge
said you know you're gonna get two weeks
and I want to see you back here and I
was like oh my god two weeks in like two
years and when I came back he stayed I
stayed behind the court room all day he
didn't see me he sent me back again for
another two weeks he did that to me a
few times that added up to three months
because the judge was like you're
Muhammad Ali's daughter like what the
heck is going on with you guys
he just want to teach me a lesson you
know and get me on track so and where
was dad throughout this whole thing you
know what he wasn't there I tell you
that he he knew what was going on but I
didn't want him to come visit me I
didn't want and you know anyone to see
my father there so he Carla everyone was
calling
what's going on with Leila like so I you
would think that I was gonna be the one
that was gonna amount to nothing you
know but obviously that didn't happen
yeah so all right so you got kind of
scared straight I mean was there was
drugs and alcohol part of that at all or
just behavior stuff no I never did I
never drank out I never did join and
drink I smoke a little weed you know but
never never did any um drug
uh-huh I always had a really good head
on my shoulders I was always strong
confident in myself it's just the anger
that I had right is what really got me
into trouble because I had this like I
said just I won't do my own thing or I
wanna I didn't want to be just I'm just
Muhammad Ali's daughter so I all of our
friends that were like our wealthy
friends kids and all that I didn't
really want to hang out around them but
I went totally to the other side of the
hood like you know and of course I
didn't have the street smarts and things
and that's how I ended up getting myself
in trouble
uh-huh yeah but sometimes that that
flirtation with the darkness is is what
you need to like you know get the needle
sorted out and get straight I wouldn't
change anything from you know and I talk
about it all the time it's I wrote a
book about it my first book was reached
fine a strange spirit and personal power
because you know when people started you
know speculating why am i fighter was
funny to me because I'm like just don't
know I hold yeah fighting my stepdad
when I was a kid I mean you know and
that's why all that started because I
didn't accept him I did accept the way
he was treating my mom I watched my mom
be weak ice tried to stand up for her
then I got mad at her like you're gonna
let this person do this to you and to us
and I had all this anger I felt
abandoned you know my dad lived in a
different state he never really know
what was going on and so it's like you
understand that you know your father is
the father to the world and he's helping
all these people but you still have to
have the isaque rifice right so it's
like that was something that I learned
at an early age and I'm not upset I
understand that's just the way the chips
yeah you didn't sign up for that
no his Energy's going out to everybody
and there's not so much left over for
for you yeah but I was actually okay
like I wasn't that close to my dad so I
wasn't like I wasn't like oh where's
daddy you know it's just that this is
what it was you know and it's fine so I
understand that he had a calling to do
certain things but that's just a part of
my story why things kind of how's your
mom doing now she's good she's good
she's on me with that guys no no I was
planning his death yeah I was like we're
gonna broke we're gonna fix those brakes
and then the cars just gonna roll down
on the PCH oh that never that never
ended up happening cuz it got out of
there but yeah she's good she um she's
you know I'm watching her journey you
know she's still she still we're just so
different as women you know so she's
still on her
her journey figuring things out for
herself but she's a psychologist she
went to school you know she's good yeah
she's got her clients oh she's great
yeah so what was the process of working
through the anger I mean did I assume
boxing played some role and helping you
get to the other side of that you don't
seem like an angry person I'm not right
so you know and it's funny because I
never thought about the process of
working through the anger but off just
off of the top of my head
definitely boxing had something to do
with it because it was a big outlet for
me because I always was a fighter like I
said for some reason I always wanted to
fight mm-hmm and prove that I was strong
you know I like I had I took pride in
that I remember being a kid and mom I
can help you move that you know picket
trying to pick up cabinets and just show
how strong I was I don't know what that
was it's gotta be some weird genetic
thing right he's very weird because I'm
telling you my husband now I always talk
about fighting did you ever ask your dad
like why why did he decide to fight at
the very beginning like what did you
feel like he shares that snared that
same it was so pulse no he's so
different than me and that my dad is and
would never do have a street fight like
my dad would never want to you know go
there like he whenever you saw him like
taunting his opponents I'm please just
playing it is all for show yeah you know
I mean but like I'm a little different
where I really have like more of a evil
mean streak when it needs to come out so
he started fighting because somebody
stole his bike he was mad about it and
trainer was like he's like I'm gonna get
those guys like what do you know how to
fight we'll come in here young man I was
like oh and then he kind of fell into it
that way whereas I'm more so was angry
and mad and then I saw women's boxing on
television for the first time it was
like oh my god I didn't even know women
box I didn't know that it was
possibility not know that nobody knew
yeah because this female Christy Martin
was on Mike Tyson's undercard back then
and it was the first time a lot of
millions of people saw it women's boxing
including myself so the first televised
yes it was the first yes it was a first
I don't want to say 100% I'm sure on
that but I know was the first big
televised attending run but I've been
watching but so she was the she was the
co-main event so people were watching I
was watching and I was like I want to do
that and then it took me about a year
of contemplation to actually start
uh-huh yes the story goes you were like
with friends watching this and you had
like it's this lightbulb moment right
and you're like I'm gonna do that I
remember like it was yesterday I was
like and you're you're like 18 right at
the time I was probably 17 yeah 17 ish
going on had no I was 18 I'm sorry I was
18 yeah hadn't hadn't played any sports
or anything like that never played
sports was not in shape my high was
about 30 pounds heavier that I needed to
because you know it's all about weight
class and getting at your best didn't
know what it would take so that night I
was like I want to do that I thought I
thought it through and everything then I
went home and the fear and the doubt and
then what are you thinking and because
remember I had already been through the
toll juvenile hall stint
right got myself back on track I had a
nail salon had a business I was in
school I was living on my own I was like
I'm gonna be an entrepreneur and I'm
gonna start all these businesses and you
know it's just at the beginning so for
me too and then I'm a planner and I do
what I say I'm gonna do so I had said
this is what I was gonna do so how am I
gonna change that was everyone think
that's crazy I don't want to be famous I
don't want to be a public person I never
did so that was just an inner conflict
in itself yeah I mean it's impossible
for you to step into that and not just
attract the white-hot spotlight of
everything and that was gonna be a
requirement in order to be successful so
remember I always think about what do I
need to do in order to make this be
successful I didn't want to just box
just to be doing for fun otherwise I
would've done it for hobby and I'm gonna
dedicate my life to this I need to be
successful at it which means I need to
be a winner I need to be undefeated I
need to make money at it I need to think
about because that's just the smart way
to approach it again so that the
traditional trajectory would be all
right you're gonna do a few fights
you're gonna figure out like you're
gonna make mistake like you can in most
people you know can anonymously like
work their way up yeah I get to a
certain point but from day one
everybody's gonna be paying attention to
you and the criticism and everything
that goes right well my pro debut put it
like this was off television because you
wanna you know you wanted if I didn't
definitely want to fight on TV and there
was 80 different media outlets there
right just ready total for this is my
first time every step
into a ring ever uh-huh and you know you
go into it your trainer your manners or
your handlers they're all like okay she
says she's gonna do this she says she's
gonna knock this girl out but what she
gonna do when those lights come on and
that crowds there and her dad's in the
audience with all this pressure you
never know until you actually go out
there and do it so then I knock the girl
out in 54 seconds and I'm like BAM right
off to a good start here right and then
it's just off to the races
yeah whole thing yeah also I think you
know almost everybody would assume that
okay you're gonna get into boxing so
first phone call dad who's the trainer
like it compiled this team of people the
best people in the world to do this but
you you did this completely without your
dad's knowledge right like you're trying
to find these people on your own yeah
well I did and my father wasn't in the
boxing business so he wouldn't have been
the best person to ask anyway but don't
if he didn't know he would have known
someone who Knight of course and then
the thing is is that with boxing you
have a lot of people with anything you
have a lot of people who are supposedly
the people who know and have the right
answer but they don't always and they
have agendas so for me a lot of that
yeah as all that so for me it was like I
wasn't gonna trust him anyway
it's like I rather make my own mistakes
because you know I already know I
already know the game so for me luckily
I found my ex-husband who was a former
fighter and we started dating and he
knew so much more than me he had been a
world champion and I remember I was
training with a guy who was asleep like
first first things first you can't train
with this guy he's just not at the level
of you know the trainer you need to be
with skill wise and experience wise so
that was the first change and then
eventually I moved to Las Vegas I
started training with them Roger
Mayweather who's Floyd Mayweather's
uncle and Floyd senior and then buddy
McGirt these are all top trainers so
those throughout my career and then you
know you see so I learn and up my level
as I needed to you know but the guy dub
Huntley who I had in LA was perfect for
the beginning of terms of just not that
when I originally had first but the
second one he you know as far as getting
my base yeah and then it was time to
kind of step it up a notch and that's
when I moved so from 17 or 18 when you
first see this fight on TV to that first
fight where like this person out how
much time went by two years few years
yeah so I saw the so I saw the saw her
on TV took me about a year to start
train
and then I trained for a whole year
before I went pro and I'm talking about
after school after work eight o'clock at
night every night and I look forward to
him and I was I was so grueling so my
whole body changed I had to change the
way that I ate you know just I was like
what is it gonna take to be a world
champion because I wanted to be a world
champion and my goal was to be
undefeated uh-huh so how many how many
how many female professional boxers were
there at that time oh I would say about
1500 yeah there's a lot and there's a
lot more now because women's boxing is
now in the Olympics yeah it wasn't when
I was fighting but my weight class which
was 168 pounds is big for a woman there
wasn't a lot of females I my whole
career I struggled with finding fights
that were gonna be you know give me a
challenge you know and that's one of the
reasons I retired I just counted it was
like the same three girls and I want to
fight it wouldn't fight me but then they
said I wouldn't fight them yeah there's
a whole lot of back-and-forth oh my god
I swear it I've lost so much sleep over
that and I was just like I'm tired of
this you know so mm-hmm
what can I do I just I just retire
there's so many other things I wanted to
do that I knew I could do well boxing
was like I got that out of my system
so it was like time to count one well 24
I know you pretty much took every belt
right like every championship or
whatever retire on top I mean it's
pretty good yeah but I mean I wasn't
really what I was gonna do I mean you
know you you I don't like ever having
people out there lingering there to be
oh she never fought this far because I
know eventually there's gonna be
documentaries made on me so there was
like you're saying I'll fight anyone
they're saying she won't fight me but it
kind of boiled down to negotiations and
people backing out over money and stuff
like that yeah definitely there's the
thing is is that to fight me was I'm the
big name right so everyone's like that's
gonna be my payday
so then with people didn't realize I
wasn't even making that much money you
know I was making a whole lot more than
them but in my mind and my world it
wasn't a whole lot of money I was making
more money outside of boxing in terms of
endorsements and things but when they
finally got their opportunity and
they're like $100,000 I thought I was
gonna get a million dollars
then it's just like wait a minute I
don't want to risk to get this
ass-whooping for that right you see what
I mean so then I was like the one girl
in particular she rather go down in
history is the one the one I was afraid
to fight opposed actually get in there
because she knew me and her like the
woman won't even look me in the eye so I
was just like she had this fear of me
but then she's got this persona because
when when someone looks mean and big and
bad and oh the pretty girl must be the
one who's afraid you know and so she's
just kind of rode that story into the
sunset when you were fighting do you do
you if you wash yourself on tape are
there similarities in style with your
dad or did you have a totally different
oh there's definitely similarities
similarities just naturally because of
our build so just the way kind of my
weight and muscle is distributed we're
built a lot alike
so when you're tall and you have long
arms you're gonna use your jab you're
gonna fight a certain way you're gonna
move around the ring and then the
natural ability to be able to move and
my speed always god-given and like from
my father so that was what I would say
we have most in common is the confidence
for one it's just like through the roof
like I literally felt like I'm gonna win
this fight with every cell in my body
for sure there was no doubt about it it
was just and I wasn't something I said
it's something I truly believed so it
was like I knew that it's just a matter
of can I go in here and do the things
that I've been working on you know as an
athlete the things that you know that
you need to perfect I want to go in
there and do and I don't know what round
is gonna happen but I know that I'm
gonna win this fight so that I think is
one thing and even even learning more
about my dad and watching videos he
wasn't even as confident as I was but
that's interesting it's because you have
to take into consideration he's fighting
bigger stronger men I didn't have that
situation on huh you see it I'm saying
yeah so tell pools will do yeah exactly
so I can't just say it's hard it's hard
to say but I never felt like like I've
heard him say like I was scared like and
I never felt that huh so but that there
was a difference there and once once the
ball was rolling and you're you're
winning all these fights does dad come
in and say here try this do that like is
he peppering you with like insights or
you just let you do your thing now he
didn't do that at all
only thing the only thing he did was
because his thing was a jab and that's
what most fighters do they'll try to
show you what they did best so it was
just like you know just yeah you gotta
have your jab fast he was just saying in
general not that it wasn't fast but he
was just like you need to hit the bag
and act like there's a fly on the bag
and you're trying to hit it before it
flies away I was like okay that's a good
one you know what I mean so just that if
that's how fast your jab needs to be but
not everyone can do it even if they want
to do it right you know so yeah and was
your training like is it different for
female boxers than it is for men is the
training exactly the same not at all
yeah I mean meaning it's not different
at all it's the same so it's just like I
don't know if it's different for running
for women as it is for men no no not at
all so the thing is with women
especially larger women I have to reign
against them in so I sparred against men
right not that you always have to but
for me that's what it ended up being
because I bring in some you've got like
okay who can I spar with him and bring
this girl in from out of town and keep
you know come to training camp for two
weeks after taking a beating day after
day they start wearing down and they're
not a help to me anymore so then it was
like okay let me just start sparring
with these guys and it kind of you just
faded out the women altogether mm-hmm
and you then you have to find the
balance because men are always going to
be stronger than we are
so then I was like okay I'm gonna spar
with 145 pound or even though I'm 168
and he still can't like crack try to
kill me you know what I mean so they
have to find that balance so you got to
find someone who's super skilled enough
to wear because if you get a fire that
doesn't have a lot of experience as
someone's like crack them they're gonna
get mad and they're not gonna be for
control himself you know what I mean I
was like yeah yeah I had Frank Shamrock
in here MMA fighter and he has this rule
it's it's it's called plus minus zero
something like that which basically
means you you have to spread your your
your efforts with different kinds of
people so you spar with the person who's
just a little bit better than you and
then you're with the person who's
perfectly matched for you and then you
work with someone who's not as good as
you like you're sort of paying it
forward to that person and when you have
blend of those three things that's like
his equation for you know progressing
efficiently that works I mean I haven't
Ivan ever broke it down in that way but
for the most part yeah you do so if you
I've been in there were people who
weren't as good as me and I'm gonna take
it easy on them but at the same time I'm
gonna try take chances that I wouldn't
normally take with somebody else yeah
you see so in this like it's a it's a
mount it's having discipline because you
can say I'm only gonna jab no matter
what no matter how hard that other
person's going and I in the back of my
mind I always have my right hand which
is hard which is gonna stop you like if
I want you to get off of me I'm gonna
hit you with that and then you're gonna
be like whoa but if I can't do that
now I got a move I got to use my feet I
have to be smart I have to do other
things so yeah it's a balance and did
you do the weight cut thing too after
the weigh-in and all that um I didn't so
you're just at 166 168 right he just
stay there 168 I'm not bad anymore I'm
200 pounds a day but 168 was my weight
and early on I'm like reacts to come in
like 164 165 easy I didn't have to lose
weight cuz I was a lean strong 164 you
know but a lot of times say if you're a
man and the lighter weights you fight
out you have less it's not as much power
to do with you want to try to come down
as small as you can because that's what
everyone else is doing so that's why
they would cut weight whereas because if
you if you if you're walking around in
175 and you try to fight at 175 as a man
you're probably fighting guys who are
really 215 and came down so I didn't
have to do that I didn't really know as
I got older I started coming around 175
because your body just changes and it
was harder for me to make 168 and I
remember having weeks the week of the
fight I had to lose 10 pounds mm-hmm
so it was just like it didn't then at
that point yeah you're like its water
weight for the most part yeah was it
ever close I mean 24 no DJ I mean did
you just like waltz through all these
people no I've had some tough fights
yeah I had some tough fights especially
I fought with the flu four times and of
course while I was fighting nobody knew
but I was like on death's door you know
like when you have a hundred two
temperature and I was like uh on fever
full-on fever full-on fever like just
weak like by the second round uh-huh I
remember I fought Joe Frazier's daughter
Jana and I was sick for that night might
have been a little press about that yeah
there was
I was sick and nobody knew and and it
was funny cuz my husband our husbands
were Co promoting the fight uh
ex-husband and I was no way I was gonna
pull out and I was just like okay she's
nothing I'm gonna there's gonna be easy
fight so I was like I could still fight
her sick you know so you get mentally
ready and I felt fine and I got in there
and by the third round I was she was
tougher than I thought she was gonna be
I was weaker than I thought I was gonna
be I'd literally by the third round was
like okay this is gonna be this is
jacked up so then like I would go back
to my corner and I wouldn't even sit
down I look I sit down I'm not gonna get
back up so I was like winning the fight
but I definitely would have stopped her
like probably by the fourth round but I
didn't have the power so that fight went
the distance and I won and then I regret
not having a rematch though for that
yeah I would I would think that that
would be a fight that there'd be a lot
of pressure to have a rematch and I
didn't write it was because of me
because I didn't have a rematch clause
and I was kind of I didn't want to fight
her in the first place because it was
right in that time when everyone wasn't
really taking me serious why is she
doing this and then she hurt her career
was inspired by mine she started and
then it it became like a side she's like
a Rocky movie yeah kids are gonna yeah
yeah I was like she's not serious I'm
serious that's how I felt and I was like
but I had to fight her because it was
like why wouldn't you and then people
want to see it there was money there but
I was like after that fight I said I
wanted to fight girls who have titles
I'm ready to start fighting real
champions so I was so adamant about that
that I was like no I'm not doing this
again
but I wish that I would have because you
know first of all what it's just been
smart business I just have you know like
I said I had something to prove and I
let that get in the way
well having something to prove and then
having all this press about like oh
she's just you know the daughter and
like having to live in that shadow
I would imagine allowed you to kind of
tap into that that that anger you know
and unleash that in the ring oh yeah I
mean I I don't I didn't just use that I
use like the anger that I feel for kids
that are abused for a sex-trafficking
whatever it is that they're just all
these things that go on in our world
that just chip away at you like when
you're watching the news and you're just
like God you know it's just like what
can you do about it like what can you
really do about it you just feel I feel
anyway like and I'm saying these are I'm
talking about now but back
come in whatever was going on back then
and during those times you know I would
just kind of make this moment bigger
than being a just about myself like I'm
going here to fight for the world so
whatever you can do mentally it's like
it really made me feel like a beast like
a monster like I'm going here to fight
this girl
I'm not going to face a war nobody don't
hit me from behind my head I'm not I see
her she's right in front of me she's got
two hands just like me and I'm gonna be
the winner period so it's just like when
you're coming in they're like you know
what I mean it was just like yeah well
that's you know that speaks to the Ali
legacy I mean the idea of making it
about something more than you right and
I mean nobody was better than that then
your dad about really using his platform
to you know call into question certain
conventional wisdoms and to speak truth
to power and to be as you know genuine
and authentic as and as honest as he
possibly could be for the betterment of
people and things that extended far
beyond boxing absolutely and he was in a
position where he was forced to have to
do it you know in terms of just
everything he was up against you know
whether going to the war and you know
fighting against going to the war and
the civil rights movement all these
things that he had right there at his
doorstep yeah I had to face so I didn't
have that situation so I never told
anybody
those are my secret things of what I
take to get into my you know super girl
suit you know what I mean to go in there
and fight I can talk about it now but it
was a little you know it's a little
different but yeah that same thing
that's in him is in me and I think that
anyone who does anything where they feel
like they're doing it for other people
and for a bigger cause understands that
people who are working for nonprofit
organizations and all this hard work
that isn't easy it's like if it was just
you maybe it was just for you maybe you
would quit or give up but you like I
can't you know so yeah I mean in the
movie he what I didn't realize or I
didn't fully appreciate was just how
bold a move it was for him to you know
speak out against the war and and opt
out of that whole thing and you see all
the other african-american athletes who
are hesitant about that and there wasn't
the Solidarity that I think
in my mind I thought was actually taking
place during that time there were
certain athletes that finally stepped up
but I mean and I say this now it's like
you can't expect everyone to be like
Muhammad Ali mm-hmm
because you know most people not just
athletes don't want to put their
livelihood on the line you know they
don't want at the time you know they
don't want to put their safety the
safety of their family on the line
especially if it's not something they
feel they truly feel they can make a
difference you have to first feel like
this is sacrifice is gonna make a change
cuz there's a lot of people to speak out
and try to make sacrifices and they feel
like it doesn't really change anything
but now they're out of a job and they're
out of their money and their kids are
you know in danger or whatever the case
may be so you know everyone's gonna do
things on my dad is special he's a
special human being you know what I mean
not just yeah you know but there were
certain athletes that got behind him you
know which was great so how do you kind
of carry that mantle forward like how do
you you know exude you know his legacy
and and try to you know continue to you
know breathe life into it through the
things in the truth the things you're
doing the choices that you made it takes
a balance for me I mean it's like now my
father's passed away he's not here
anymore I think about that more because
before that it was kind of like him what
am I gonna do like I said for me and my
life and a lot of it naturally happened
the things that I care about I try not
to I don't want to be a burden on me
because as great as my father was an
amazing you know all the changes he made
in the world I still have my life to
live yeah you know the real guy when the
cameras aren't oh man so come on like
that's that's what that's what that he
shaped my view of of people like okay
this these people are looking up to this
guy no I'm just joking yeah but um when
none of us are perfect but I'm just
saying I am really passionate about
health and wellness and encouraging
people to be the absolute best version
of themselves similar to what you're
into doing and this becomes very natural
to me I've done it myself I'm still
doing it myself it's an ongoing process
and I try to this confidence that I have
that I wish I could put it in a bottle
is something I was born with but I wish
that for everyone that they
had enough self-love because I think
that's what it really comes down to his
confidence starts with self-love and you
have to love yourself enough to know
that you're not gonna be perfect you're
gonna make mistakes and that's okay like
I was just saying a few minutes ago
I my father being as amazing as he is he
wasn't nowhere near perfect so as a kid
I watched that I saw his mistakes I know
all the things about him that are like
what crazy you know but he still is this
amazing human being so I'm like if he is
not perfect nobody is you know what I
mean so first you just have to know that
because most people are afraid to go
after the things they really want to do
they say the things they really want to
feel to really you know find their
purpose because they're afraid of
screwing up you know they're afraid of
what people are gonna say and it's like
when you don't have that feeling your
the possibilities are limitless yeah
it's hard it's really hard you know and
just looking at your dad as an example
like he wasn't afraid to say ever he
wasn't ever afraid to say what he
thought no matter what people thought
like he was completely divorced from
public opinion about his behavior and
his actions and and that's you know
what's so inspiring and empowering about
his example and I think most people walk
around myself included
you know second-guessing myself and I
think there's an epidemic of people just
feeling like they're not enough you know
and there's a lot of pressure especially
in the digital Instagram age of
measuring ourselves against other people
or the you know public facing image of
other people and it's very easy to just
feel like you know what do I have to
contribute and I you know I can't make a
difference and and you know how can I be
you know how can I excel in all these
different categories there's all these
expectations and pressures on me and
it's impossible so people just retreat
into their self-loathing
you know I know and and I may I see it
all the time and that's exactly what I'm
talking about it's like I really one of
the things that I want to do and when
you asked me carrying on the torch and
I'm like okay so what can I do
obviously I'm already doing you know
through my website layali calm and
through my speaking and through my
products and just my whole Laila Ali
lifestyle brand is empowering people to
be the best they can be and I'm talking
I start with nutrition and food but it's
about empowerment empowering your
mindset empowering your purpose
empowering your your health replenishing
I'm sorry replenishing all those things
but then I want to go deeper so I
actually want to do a process that you
know people can download to kind of find
that confidence so that's something that
I wouldn't be able to do by myself right
now it's just an idea but it's something
that I really want to do and I really
want to start with young girls you know
in women and then kind of just go from
there so it's just an idea that I have
because I think that that is the basis
of what you said is that self-love and
you know really just accepting yourself
for who you are first you have to do it
before anybody else will then just kind
of moving on from there so yeah so what
does that process look like for you for
me yeah like like I mean if you were to
if you were to like I know you're it's
just an idea at this point but if you
were to like hash out like alright
here's how I would take somebody through
a process of helping them to do that in
their own life I think that it
definitely is gonna be a series of you
know items I mean things that you're
gonna read things you're gonna download
or workbooks to write to work things out
because you have to figure out a lot of
things within yourself you know and
people have to be ready to put that
mirror in front of him that's the one
thing that you need to do first
so I mean working with other individuals
who you know because the thing for me my
struggle is I'm naturally confident
right so it's like how can you tell yeah
happen you just tell someone but but
they're things that I'm not as confident
about so you know so I can relate to
certain things like people would think
that like I said when I go into the ring
I'm winning this fight no question about
it but I'm not that way with everything
else
uh-huh so like for now I have to
challenge myself because other
opportunities always come up for me and
then I'll be like for example someone
say oh we want you to come speak at this
college or whatever I'm like oh I didn't
even finish school like what am I gonna
say to them and I get a little insecure
like why would I go up there and talk
and then out like no I don't want to do
it then my business partner push me no
you need to go do this and I'm my I have
fear I'm like no I don't want to go do
it I'm not because I'm not that smart
when it comes to book smarts you know
I'm like so I have a insecurities
they're like
literally like I don't want to go on
trivia you know shows or game shows
things like that cuz I don't want people
to know how much I don't [ __ ] know
you know what I mean like really like
I'm like because I missed out on a lot
of school so like that is an insecurity
and so so what's the solution for you
for that you got us to that stuff yeah
you not all of it no no no part here
yeah yeah but but definitely to I have
to say like I tell my friends on my f
fear like just do it just take a chance
so sometimes that's what I have to do I
have to say I'm just gonna go for it you
know I'm gonna put it out there and then
once I've done it I'll be like okay you
know I can look process it and say I'm
not gonna do it again or at least I did
it that one time or I learned some bad
you know about myself so yeah yeah well
self-love begins with self acceptance
and and you know I like what you said
about the mirror like you got to be able
to look in the mirror and hold yourself
accountable to yourself and I think you
know a big I think it begins with
understanding that fundamentally most
people seek that through external inputs
like if I can get that person to date me
or if I can get that car or that job or
whatever that that's gonna solve the
problem and the truth is that's the
wrong way to look at it like it begins
with the inside you have to turn that
gaze inward and start to you know
deconstruct whatever's going on inside
of you and unpack like whatever
whether it's childhood trauma or
whatever your repetitive you know
behavior patterns that hold you back are
just fully understanding those and
accepting yourself for having those I
think is at the beginning of trying to
work through them to get to the other
side
we're so complex as human beings you
know it's like I can I can be watching
this podcast and be inspired and go man
I want to do that you know and then it's
just like it's is really about working
on certain things and being focused and
consistent with you you know it's like
you can't think of everything all at
once or it just becomes overwhelming and
nothing gets done yeah you know so it's
just like how about like just not going
to Burger King for your next meal like
let's yeah all right yeah well I
remember I met this gentleman on the
airplane and he was like 400
overweight and we just got to talk and I
talked to him for the whole flight it's
like a five-hour flight by the end of
the flight you know he talked about his
struggles his ups and downs and why he
wasn't able to lose weight and I said
look wudu you so what are gonna go eat
after you you know get off this plane
let's just be honest he's like I'm gonna
go get like a quarter two quarter
pounders a large fry and a large
supersize drink I was like okay can you
go get one quarter pounder a fry and a
medium drink he's like I mean do you
really think you can do that it was like
yeah I think I can do that or something
just start there that's a win just start
there I said and then you know ease then
didn't get to where you get a small fry
and then and then get to where can you
eat a salad before you go get like a lot
of times we think about all these things
we need to stop doing and my thing is
like okay for those people who really
just feel like they just keep failing
all the time it's almost like they
subconsciously expect to fail because I
haven't been able to to get past certain
things they're trying to do so instead
of thinking about all the things you
have to take away what can you add like
don't even think about taking anything
away just can you get a smoothie in for
breakfast and then if you're still
hungry go ahead and have that cinnamon
roll whatever you know what I mean and
then can you just get a green salad
before your meal can you drink a glass
of water okay let's just start adding
these things stop thinking about what we
need to take away then they start first
of all you're gonna feel fuller they're
gonna get some nutrients they're gonna
start cutting out you know some of the
other food that they let's just start
with that like let's not you know cuz
it's just so many things no you just
need to do this to be healthy you just
need to do that you do that it's very
overwhelming you know so that works well
for a lot of people that I that I've you
know worked with yeah I think the more
granular you can make it and you break
these things down that are so
overwhelming that it just prevents
people from ever even beginning into the
smallest you know little chunks then it
becomes digestible and you know
self-esteem comes with performing a
schema will act and that applies to you
know service to others but it also
applies to service to ourselves right
and so you know if that guy like hey can
you take the stairs and not the
escalator when you get off the plane or
just like the just like one thing and
once you do that you're like oh I did
that I can do that next time too
I feel a little bit better than I would
if I'd done that other thing
so now you feel more energized and more
emotionally connected to the process and
you're more likely to make that better
choice the next time around as well and
then that stuff builds exactly and I
think you know I said this many times
before but I think people overestimate
the progress that they can make in a you
know a month or six months and they
wildly underestimate the progress that
they could make in a year so that guy on
the plane if he just did tiny little
things but he was consistent about it
like a year from now you know maybe he's
lost a hundred pounds and he's not done
but he's like on his way and and he did
it in a way where it didn't even feel
that painful because it was so gradual
that's what I'm always always saying I'm
like six months from now you either
gonna be healthier and have lost weight
you're gonna be the same or you're gonna
gain weight so it's like just make these
small changes and you look up you know I
just I just even for myself I mean I
fall off the wagon sometimes because I
was healthy ten years ago and I'm
healthier now you know because the
obvious things I did you know when I
first started boxing I was like okay you
know you gotta eat healthier but I still
didn't really understand quality of food
and organic food and non GMOs and all
those things I wasn't at that level yet
but it was like I was always on this
quest to get better you just want to
make sure you're trying to get better
and you're you're you know actually
starting some sort of a process there's
gonna be mistakes along the way you know
you're gonna you know find out new
information all these people that try
all these different eating styles
they're trying to figure out what works
for them what they can actually you know
do for the rest of their life but it's
gonna change even then like I can't eat
the same way that I did five years ago
even you know as your body changes as
you get older you know you just you just
have different needs
I think this self-love applies to
accepting yourself for making those
mistakes too because I think people set
themselves up for long-term failure when
they have a slip-up
or they make a mistake and then they
just give up they're like well it's too
hard you know it's like now you just
that's just feedback you know yeah like
let's let's try to figure out why you
made that choice maybe you don't make it
next time and just be more gentle on
yourself and a little bit more
permissive of those mistakes and use it
all as a learning experience
as opposed to you know a cane to like
you know to like smack yourself with I
just love that there's so many resources
people have now for help because you
know it's like you can listen to this
one conversation and try to go do this
by yourself and then you don't have that
voice in your you know and that support
like what you just said it's like people
need to hear that on a regular basis you
know because you're gonna slip up and
you're gonna have issues you're gonna
need to reset you're gonna need to
remind yourself because then life
happens you know what I mean it's like I
start off like I'm gonna do this this is
net and I'm doing it and then at some
point I stop and then like months go by
I look back okay I stopped doing that
because something happened it took my
attention right that when you interrupt
a momentum yeah oh wait oh god I gotta
get back on that you know so what do you
think holds people back the most I fear
and that's gonna be so many things you
know fear and then probably just their
habits like you just have a habit things
that they just can't let go of mm-hmm
you know and like I just like I just
asked that off the top of my head but
that definitely holds people back from
following their dreams following their
heart Taking Chances fear yeah and then
in terms of just reaching their goals
and a lot of what you talked about is
health and wellness goals it's just you
know their habits you know and and we
have to like you know it's like we want
to be gentle but the same time you need
to give yourself a kick in the ass
sometimes I have to do it sometimes like
when I'm you know when I'm when I fall
off and I'm having more sugar than I
need to have she's like just you girl
stop it like I have a coach in my own
head though just stop like I don't like
feeling like I can't be in control of my
own myself and my own actions so it's
like but that's the thing that's that's
a my thing not everybody feels that way
yeah but it's like when I start feeling
like wait a minute I just put that in my
mouth I didn't even think about it it's
just so then I hate it and I was like I
don't even want to eat that but I was
stressed out you know and I had a weak
moment and it was around and I liked it
you know so then it was just like boom
yeah you know I mean and then then
that's when I'm like okay you're not
do that again you know and I'd like set
a boundary for myself
uh-huh but I could probably do it again
are you kidding me like we're good
beings you know it's like yes but the
only thing that we have control over our
our actions and our reactions right
right and but but I think more often
than not that's like running on you know
our unconscious mind is controlling most
of that most of the time and the more
mindful and kind of rooted in the
present that we can be then we're more
aware of when we're reflexively like
doing those kinds of things but it's
hard and I think we have this sense that
we can control our environments better
than we actually can we really can't you
know there's there's people and
variables and things happen and I think
people sort of set these goals or
begin these trajectories to you know
improve themselves in some various way
and there'll be some interceding event
that interferes with like their plan
mm-hmm and they're like well I can't do
it it's like but that's that's the way
the world works like you got to learn
how to roll with that [ __ ] mm-hmm if you
want to stay in it and staying in it is
the is is is the winning strategy what I
do is I expect that there's gonna be
some some kind of a disrupter not in a
negative way like cause you don't want
just have to be negative about
everything but in terms of like I like
to just know things are gonna happen so
when they happen it's not that big of a
deal to me it's like you know I'm gonna
jump over that I must do this I'm gonna
do that I must say it's like it's like a
game you know right so if just staying
on track so I know that everyone has a
different way of thinking but like you
said you can't control anyone else you
can only control your own actions and
how you respond to certain situations
and I I'd like to take responsibility
for my own actions so when things don't
go my way or something happens I always
think what could I have done differently
even if it comes down to something
someone else did and someone could say
well no that wasn't on you that was on
them I'm like what I might have chose to
put that person in the picture in my
life
yeah let me think why I did that and how
I can prevent those because those red
flags were there so I I can still bring
it back to the choice I made you know
and just try to figure that's how
serious I am about it like I try to
figure out okay how can I just change
things but then again I can't get too
caught up in that all
so because I can't be in that much
control all the time so that's the mind
I'm a control freak you know but you can
always do an inventory right always I
think no matter you know how many people
tell you you were right and they were
wrong right I guarantee you that you
contributed to whatever happens in some
way and the more skilled you can become
at identifying what your part is because
I think that's another thing where our
unconscious mind takes over and we're
like I didn't do anything wrong and you
need other people in your life to call
you on that stuff and say actually
here's here's what you keep doing all
the time and you're not even aware that
you're doing it and that's why you keep
ending up in these right shitty
situation right and if you don't want to
call it wrong just what can you do
differently to have a different outcome
keep doing the same thing you don't have
the same outcome we hear it all the time
is like okay why why are you doing yeah
don't you think maybe it's dry for you
Leila it's easy for you your your this
and that and the other thing like you
don't understand my problems right you
know and it's tough to break through out
of that you know I'm sympathetic to that
but so alright so you conclude your your
your boxing career and now you're like
in this you know you're this like
wellness entrepreneur like how did that
come about like how did you decide like
this is the this is the Avenue I want to
pursue so when I retired from boxing
I go went through with most athletes go
through when they retire it's just kind
what am I gonna do now alright because I
did what I love then when I was
passionate about and I put my all into
and it took me about five or six years
to really figure that out because I was
you know I had all these opportunities
with TV hosting all that but I wasn't
really fulfilled and I only loved being
on TV it's like something I do because I
know I need to do but I'm not like that
person like I want to be on TV you know
it's just good for business but I
realize I'm really passionate about
helping people with their health and
their wellness I'm right now meal plans
for friends and always helping people
and I was like you know what can how can
I make this a business for myself for
this something that I can really focus
on and that's when I started Leilani
lifestyle brand and I started my website
and my blog and you know I had a podcast
at one time and I came out with my
cookbook food for life now I have
Leilani spice blends which are like my
baby I brought some for you yeah
I'm so excited about those and then I
have a nutrition line called you
punished so and I'm very hands-on when I
say hands-on I'm talking about down to
the alcohol go Google and be like whom
we find the organic spice company and
I'll call him up and say hmm you know
how was the minimum order and I'm like
dealing with these people when it comes
to my labels and everything because I
wanted to really approach it like any
other entrepreneur who was just starting
and I'm also you know like I don't like
to wait on people someone I want to
answer I'll get it for myself so that's
why I do most things myself because like
I wanted to pick up a phone a call right
now not only that there's no blueprint
to what it is that I was what I'm trying
to do so you know I you know when it
came to this the spice winds even it was
just like there was officer who can I
call that's done this before yeah they
can help me and not look at me as Laila
Ali you know like look at me is just a
regular female entrepreneur you know
because then it's like oh we can put you
with this person and they can you know
then they want to be a part of the deal
and it becomes something as not and I
was like no I don't want that I want to
have to answer anyone so that's been a
fun quest for me because I'm making a
lot of mistakes along the way we talk
about mistakes but I wouldn't have it
any other way and it took me like five
years to finally get my spice blends
packaged and ready to sell so they're up
online and the spice blends were so
important to me because ever since I was
nine years old I've been cooking and
when I told you we moved to Malibu and
you know I had the dysfunctional
childhood we had a house there was a big
house and it was a guest house in a
house connected so my sister and I lived
in the guest house we had our own
kitchen my mom didn't cook and I learned
to cook at an early age and I was always
really good at flavoring foods seasoning
food so that's really what makes the
difference between people's restaurants
you know so I had a real talent for that
balancing flavors I've even competed on
chopped oh yeah oh yeah I'll come back
okay yeah I competed on chopped and won
twice oh yeah well I did twice yeah yeah
I'm chopped champion I'm proud I'm proud
of that yeah and it was a flavor so it
was a it was the seasoning and so I
started the spice blends because I think
that anyone can take plants vegetables
and you know if you have a good
seasoning
you know then you can taste amazing so I
have organic non-gmo spice blends and
I'm gonna I'm gonna add to the line and
yes I feel it was a real accomplishment
that's cool did you teach yourself how
to cook or how did you learn how to do
that
I pretty much taught myself I called my
grandma a couple times and said grandma
my grandma's from Louisiana I was like
you know I remember the first time I was
making a gumbo so how do you make roux
and she told me over the phone
and you know I just perfected it from
then on so I've called her over the
phone I've learned a lot just like a lot
of people do watching watching on TV you
know it's a kid yeah but yeah most of
the cooking is all on my own but I'm not
you know I'm definitely just a home cook
like I'm not and I don't bake because
that's something you really have to know
what you're doing science behind it yeah
that's a specific yeah that's not really
my thing but yeah cooking yeah I throw
down you got your hands on a lot of
stuff your it reminds me do you know
John Salley I do yeah he's like guys all
over the place every time I see him he's
got some new business oh right the vegan
wines and he's got yeah this company and
he's got I mean it's crazy like his he
has so much energy and he's so
passionate about so many different
things and he's has this entrepreneurial
spirit and he keeps giving birth to like
all these different I mean a lot of its
nutrition oriented but like even other
things as well yeah I got the spice
blends so I have lai la Lee lifestyle
and then I believe in you know with me
I've had shakes since I was boxing I'd
have a smoothie or a shake because it
was just like okay how can I get all
this nutrition in without actually
having to eat give my body a break from
breaking the food down so after I'd go
running in the morning I'd get up run
the mountains come back I'd have a shake
so I'm not after I did all that work I'm
not gonna make my body work again to
digest food then I go to sleep then I
wake up and have my breakfast and then I
have another shake after I worked out
again so that's I've been doing shake so
long so even now I have a shake for
breakfast because it's like I don't want
to have to think about my maca powder
and my green powder my all these things
and all these nutrients I'd rather just
get it all in my shake no I got it in
one thing yeah and then everything else
is just on top of that so that's why for
me that's one of the easiest ways for
people who aren't currently getting the
nutrition they need is like okay why
don't you just have a shake you know and
just make sure it's in there and then
it's not so overwhelming and just make
that part of your daily nutrition so and
then just
the basics like vitamins you know Green
powders I have a 14-day cleanse for a
lot of people just need to cleanse that
up all that out it's not coming out so
you know the nutrition is one thing but
then the cooking is just teaching people
that you know if food doesn't have to be
complicated you know it doesn't have to
be complicated it's just like but we
definitely definitely want to have
amazing flavors when we do eat we've
we've lost our connection with cooking
in so many ways like people are just
busy man we live our lives are so
fast-paced now that people don't learn
how to cook and you know then it just
becomes intimidating and you just think
well I never learned how to do that and
I'm probably never will and the truth is
most of it's pretty simple food pretty
cool yeah they don't they don't know how
and the logic on just don't want to take
the time because like you said it seems
so overwhelming but like literally you
know it's like when you learn how easy
it is especially if you just want to
throw something in the oven and roast
you know you can roast some veggies on a
pan and season them up with a little bit
of oil then you're done you know it's
like they're like okay I get it
you know but even if for those who are
aren't cooking it's like at least when
you do eat you know get your food
something from somewhere that you know
has quality food you know so cuz some
people just aren't gonna stop and cook
yeah I love to cook and I understand
that food the love that goes into
cooking the energy that goes on cooking
like whenever you're in a restaurant
even though who's in the back of that
kitchen cooking your food and what
they're feeling and they're mad and
what's going on their life they're there
for your food and giving it to you
you're eating that energy no I do - no I
do - that's why I've like soul food
that's why that came about when all the
women in the kitchen you know and
African American Muni and they sat
around they're sitting there and there's
this family together and you're chopping
up the potatoes and you're you know
you're peeling this and doing that and
it's like all the love that goes into
that it's something you know yeah so and
a lot of things have changed we don't we
don't cook as much we don't sit around
the table and eat together
yeah we're not as healthy as we used to
be you know all this stuff is connected
yeah meanwhile we can sit around and
talk about you know maca powder and
green smoothies and things like that but
the real battlefield is trying to get
people
away from pulling into the drive-through
mm-hmm you know yeah and speaking to
that you know population of people that
are suffering from diabetes and obesity
and heart disease at just alarming rates
like that's I feel like you know we need
more solutions and focus on trying to
provide healthy nutrition and education
and affordable solutions to people who
have a good argument when they say
listen you know I don't have time I'm
working two or three jobs and I don't
have the budget you know I can't go get
all these healthy foods and and I it's
just you know I've got a kid screaming
in the back I'm just gonna I'm pulling
through the drive-thru done of taking
care of it yeah and you're talking about
especially in african-american community
mm-hmm
which is one of the reasons why I'm so
passionate about you know that the you
know educating that I do because a lot
of people's like they don't know they
they just don't know better they don't
even realize that what they're eating a
lot of times people know obviously
burgers and fries and pizza are
unhealthy but I'm talking about just
even when they think they are eating
something that's healthier you know this
process and has all these chemicals in
it it's not even food
it's food like you know and it's like
somebody's sitting around an office
trying to figure out what chemicals they
can put in it to make you want it more
and be addicted to it you know I mean
it's like you really want to educate
people about that and then also teach
them ways that okay I know that it got
trapped in here with us so you have
people who they say it to me all the
time when I can't afford to eat that way
you know and it's like okay well we need
to figure out how we can eat you don't
have to have these you know high-end
meals every night it's like an you you
know even if it's rice and beans there's
a lot of nutrients and beans you know
and it's like I am a meat eater but I
have reduced the amount of meat that I
eat for multiple reasons but when I do
eat I eat you know organic Jim you know
GMO free free rein you know all the
highest-quality I can get but I'm always
telling people also it's like reduce the
amount of animal foods that you eat you
know and because not everybody you know
ready to go vegan right you know so it's
just like but you can get to the point
where you know 75% of the food on your
plate is plant-based food yeah I mean
setting the whole vegan thing aside you
know people you know meat meat began as
like a delicacy side dish and at some
point we decided that that has to
predominate our plates and we just eat
insane amounts of meat right now and I
just think there's no question that it's
contributing to a lot of the problems
and you certainly processed food and
sugar and all I'm you know I'm not
dismissing any of that but I think we
could all benefit from pressure reducing
our intake definitely I think you know
like I said no matter even if you're not
a vegan or vegetarian it's like even if
you're a meat-eater like me I think that
you definitely need to reduce them out
you don't need to be eating meat every
single meal you don't need to be meeting
at every single day and when you do eat
it it should be a very small portion of
meat you know on your plate so how's the
what does the fitness workout of a
routine look like for you these days I
mix it up so right now I'm really liking
so I'll have a heavy bag I have a home
gym uh-huh I usually hit the heavy bag
like four rounds 15 minutes and then I
will ask Mike my warmup yeah then I will
get on my warmup and then I get and then
I get on my elliptical stairs
and and I'll get on my elliptical stairs
and I have a treadmill so I might do
like some you know high-intensity
training some sprinting on my treadmill
and then I have a infrared sauna I like
to incorporate that at the end of my
workout I get clear light one a Sun
lighting uh-huh oh cool and I get in I
get in there for like thirty minutes
after my workout but then I'll you know
I might do some free weights I like to
mix it up but I also love to run but my
knees aren't that that good so I'm like
you know we all just built different so
I've been told not to run but I still
run you know and ice my knees and it's
just like it's really hard so like if I
run I literally I can have not ran for
two years but I can go out there and
just do four or five miles because just
still in me but at by the end of five
miles I'm like oh I'm looking like that
last mom looking like okay when's this
gonna be over and I love running around
here like I just go on a Gore road and
yeah straight up you know wait the
trailers wallet trails at the end lost
version is to like all around oh yeah I
don't like running in the mountains oh
no I'm a little funny about about my
yeah yeah yeah I'm like I'm good than my
husband my husband like you don't go out
there by yourself by bad friends yeah oh
just just period just people out there
and you know just you just never know
and then I'm gonna I'm recognized there
all the time
oh well then I'd go I'd go with me I'd
go gee I can't run as far as you that's
alright whatever those I call him the
crazy runners I did at the New York City
triathlon oh you did yeah and that was
crazy
Wendy's a couple years ago I was the mom
ambassador photographer and know this
was like probably seven six years ago
huh where they do it in the Hudson
mm-hmm yeah and I've never done a
triathlon I've never done anything so I
was just like they asked me to do it I
was like yeah athlete I know as they put
me with this trainer triathlon trainer
she came out here for one two days and
she was like okay we're gonna get on the
bike because I've never been on a bike
to ride so she's like we're gonna we
went we rode up a girl rode 25 miles so
we went 12 miles one way and then came
back something like that and then we ran
I got off that bike and just running a
mile was so hard just cuz I was just so
you know like just rocked uh so long
story short I ended up taking on this
show didn't train like I was supposed to
so I did the one bike ride with her that
wasn't the one twenty five mile bike
ride and then I was swimming in the at
Calabasas tennis clinic for forty five
minutes I was like I'm so swim for forty
five minutes
I went to the open water one time to the
beach and I was so nervous about it my
friends were like come on
so we swam to the buoys and I was like
take me out freighter sharks I was like
I'm never doing that again they're like
if you can get in this ocean then you
can go get in the Hudson so I got so
when I got there I was like these people
are crazy like they were up with their
bikes at 4:00 a.m. like walking to the
water it's like a like they're so
serious about it that whole thing and
everyone was like if you do it one time
you're gonna fall in love with it you're
gonna do it again I was like we'll see
so I jump in that Hudson swam did the
run I mean I did the bike and I was
afraid to switch gears uh-huh
because I didn't really like the track
would come literally only rode a bike
one time I Lulu
one time so then you bro the trial on in
the same gear the whole time no I
changed it was one side I was fooling
with but I wouldn't fight with other
side so it was harder for me because I
didn't know how to use a bike because I
was like if this chain comes off I'm
gonna be on the side and it was gonna be
a whole thing so I did it but I finished
in three hours in four minutes for you
so I was I did it I did it and when I
came off like when I came through the
finish line it was so crazy all of a
sudden my I blacked out
my eyes were open but I blacked out and
I told my guy that was with me I was
like Darrell I can't see so he held my
hand he was like you're so hot I was so
hot I went to the tents where you lay
down and it took about thirty seconds
for my vision to come back uh-huh and I
was just laying there for like being
worked on
you know rubbed out and all that for
like an hour and then I got up and also
no super hungry and they had doughnuts
and all these things I was just like
pick it out and I was like I'm never
doing that usually one or the other it's
either like I can't wait to do it again
or like them I did it I'm it's over with
oh my God look at you like I was
different I can't punch anyone so like
you're running all these miles like oh
my god like what makes you want to do
that well you let like you we were
joking before the podcast like you're
the first person who lives local to me
right here and it's usually it's like
gigantic drive out here right like out
and down oh you know yeah but this is
where all the beautiful trip I mean the
nature around here is insane like once
you and I lived out here for years
before I got into this kind of stuff and
I didn't even realize it was like all
going on around here until you start
getting out there and exploring it I
thought your interview with some of your
interview with Lindsey Vonn and like you
like come out here with me like a side
out here I don't want to come back yeah
you you you have like I was thinking
about Lindsey cuz your trajectory is
somewhat similar like retiring from the
sport you know having a certain level of
like Fame and notoriety and success and
like trying to now translate your unique
life experience into you know this
wellness channel where you can be like
you know a mentor and and somebody who
who can provide you know products is for
people
so she's done pretty cool you know she's
doing cool things but that's great I
think that um you know and there's gonna
be those who have done in that's not
their passion you know I just really
believe in following your passion and I
truly am passionate about and I you know
we all have a different audience right
of people in different levels of health
and wellness that people are on I like
to really get those people who were just
like I'm healthy I only drink clear soda
right you know we got that I remember
the first time I heard that I'm like
what you just so you know cuz I don't
drink the dark soda like okay you know
so I though cuz I can really speak to
them in a way that they understand it's
not over their head right you know so
that is one thing cuz I'm not over the
top like I'll still go get a glazed
doughnut there's a place called Blinky's
in Woodland Hills I got the best oh my
god now look I'm telling you I'm that
girl like I understand health and
wellness and I understand that the fried
doughnut and the refined sugars not good
for me but guess what if I love it that
much I'm gonna live my life and I'm
having one every once in a while because
I'm stronger than that's gonna kill me
having it that one time but I'm not
gonna go do that every day you know so
it's like I can really relate to people
because like I have that person living
inside me there's still like I just want
to go to Popeyes and get some fried
chicken but I'm not because that's not
high quality chicken you know all the
kind of different things but I I still
crave some of those things is what I'm
saying so I can relate to those
individuals and then your relatable to
the to those people yeah exactly exactly
kind of like your conversation with the
guy in the airplane like what is when
you when you're when you're confronted
with somebody like that like what do you
what do you say so that you keep it
grounded and relatable and not over
their head first of all they die it's
okay I understand you know because a lot
of times people are ashamed but first of
all they're not even comfortable in
their own skin I mean he had to get
miles what do you call them extenders oh
yeah you know yeah and just just to take
the time to listen to someone people
people would even think me as Laila Ali
would sit there and talk to you for five
hours you know so it was like just to
know that someone cares and that I'm not
judging you
that's one thing and but let's try to
figure out how we can make it
you know and and everything that you
have tried before hasn't worked okay
let's do this a little differently so a
lot of times it's just like the comfort
and the whole emotional thing behind the
eating in the first place is there you
know this this person not as strong as
me where they can just say I'm just not
gonna do it boom you know what I mean
because of whatever it is they're
dealing with that I can't relate to but
I do know that what really has worked
well is just what can we add opposed to
what we need to take away uh-huh
you know and you got to take baby steps
baby steps in the right direction so and
I told him I was like yeah reach out to
me and let me know how you're doing he
never did he didn't know he never did he
might have lost herbaceous rill to be
sitting next year though he was so cool
I mean he didn't act like he was like oh
my god you know he kinda was just kind
of down on himself but we had this whole
conversation but he felt good by the end
of the conversation and I see a little
spark in his eyes like yeah I think I
can do that I think I can go get a meat
and fry instead of a large fry so I said
okay yeah you know but I just appreciate
that he was honest with me about what he
was gonna go get mm-hmm you know so I
was I had hope I had hope for him you
know
well the follow-up is is the tough thing
it's like he's probably thinking I
should reach out to her but he yeah she
doesn't really want to hear you know
like there's a self-defeating narrative
that takes over oh yeah we might have
good like me and just lost my
information cuz I do it all the time
people give me some and how does that
work with trying to get somebody active
for the first time same you know small
chunks kind of advice yeah I mean it
depends on the situation cuz a lot of
people that I'm dealing with I can't
touch them and reach out to them and you
know work with them individually but
it's really I really encourage people to
get with a partner or get with a friend
get with someone who you guys can hold
each other accountable because that's
what we need we need to be held
accountable because when it's just
yourself sometimes I know I'm not
getting out of bed nobody's gonna know
but if you have a friend you like okay I
want to be there for her you know I want
to I don't you know I'm gonna have her
back so just being accountable taking
small steps we just have this
all-or-nothing attitude you know and we
have this I want to lose this much
weight by this much time it's like just
make progress each week try to go in
account for some setbacks
well change changing habits that you
convinced
Stane because it's about changing your
lifestyle it's not about some goal was
that end date it's about behavioral
change that you can live with for the
rest of your life well I tell people
even because I added a 14-day cleanse
and it's part of my product and yeah you
lose some weight but you know there's
those people just want to lose weight
well I'm going on this vacation mm-hmm
it's like okay whatever it's a business
if you're that person and that's height
why you want to do the cleanse are still
good that you did a cleanse but I always
encourage people after you're done with
the cleanse you need to go on to the
meal planning guide that I've provided
because if you want to maintain those
results you know then that's what you
need to do because it's a lifestyle
change it's like don't go you know
cleanse and then just go put the same
old crap back in your body and all that
type of thing so if you really want to
be on this journey and that's what my
whole like I said platform and website
is about then you need to start thinking
differently about how you go into it and
then your purpose because again we all a
lot of people have had health scares and
that's when they're like oh I want to
change my life and that's fine I'm not
gonna judge you I'm glad you're finally
ready but you know it has to be a
lifestyle change you know because for me
what inspires me is not to be a certain
size yeah I like to look good yeah I'd
like to feel fit I don't like extra fat
on my body that's one thing that bothers
me because I know I understand that it's
probably also wrapped around your organs
and it's extra weight and it's just I'm
not at my best and I know what it feels
like to be at my best so that's what I'm
always chasing yeah right but at the
same time what was I going to say
I lost my thought not being not be
knowing what it's like to be at your
best no you know how being connected to
that feeling and yeah not being perfect
that's the boxer you know
yeah well punchy sometime you never got
punched doled out the beating no I was
far with men I was taking a beating in
the gym that's why the that's why the
fights were easy but that's a blurry
badge do you worry about like TBI or and
I worry but I literally just lost my
train of thought so it's like I always
think yeah that has something to do it
has affected me because my memory
sometimes like be I've ran into people
that are like hey Layla and I'm like
look familiar like I'm God I know I'm
yeah but you mustn't probably meet
no but this can be a person that
literally was like we went to high
school together like we hung out
together like on a daily basis like I
really don't
which high school yeah and I'm just like
hey and then I might come to me later oh
yeah but I'm like how could I not
remember that great yeah
philanthropy like giving back service
you know these are these are big these
were big things with your dad and and
you know you do a lot of that as well so
how does like your dad's example inform
like how you think about giving back it
comes natural to me I naturally want to
give I naturally want to help people I
have certain organizations that I work
with I love working with feeding America
I have a friend who has a man that for a
long time right uh-huh yeah I have a
friend that has an organization called
peace for kids which is smaller it's
here in LA and it's for kids and in
homes so I'll I'll donate a lot of times
there and go go down and into Compton
and work with them and you know so I get
involved with organizations that I'm
really feel like I can get behind I've
been involved the women's Sports
Foundation for many years some power and
girls and women through sports so cuz
there's just so many causes but most of
what I do is just trying to give back
through like a lot of what I want to do
with Li la Li spice blends is donate a
portion of the proceeds to various
different organizations so because I
believe that that's what we're all
supposed to do mm-hmm so you know it's
just like in it whether it's giving up
your time or your money or whatever the
it may be like giving back in some sort
of way and you have two kids parent
right so how do you how do you instill
in your children like this ethos that
your dad represented and that you're you
know exuding in your own life like how
what what are the techniques like by
which you're raising these kids to try
to ensure that they're healthy and happy
and and you know care about these things
that your dad cared about and that you
care about I'm figuring out along the
way how are your kids
my my son is 10 and my daughter's eight
and I do a lot I let my my spirit guide
me a lot my intuition guide me so I I
have
my general idea of what I want to do but
it's not like a set plan mm-hmm so
because like my son you never know what
you're gonna get with your kids you know
he's so like you would think I would
think he was gonna be like this strong
tough kind of boy and he's that he's got
the kindest sweetest heart and he's just
like Tim McVeigh he's a huh you know
he's just like and I'm like man my son
but he's strong he's a leader but he's a
gentle kind leader
but he's got the sweetest heart and I
worry about him like Oh God you know
he's just so gentle and kind and sweet I
just wish you were a little stronger but
he is who he is he doesn't belong to me
he came to this world through me and my
daughter is like this little feisty
she's like just like me mm-hmm and I'm
just like oh man I got my hands full
with her so it's like they know who
their grandfather is and they really got
a real piece of it when we went out to
Louisville when he passed away and we
went and they saw you know the person oh
they're old enough to remain yeah and
they were very overwhelmed by it like oh
my god because they didn't realize the
magnitude so they have a lot of pride
there's certain thing but I didn't take
them to see the Olly movie because I
knew there's things in there that I'm
not ready to explain to them yet mm-hmm
like my kids obviously it's when you
when you're a parent you're black and
you have kids we have to raise our kids
differently because it's like in way the
best way I can explain it is it's like
you know as a parent you think okay what
am I gonna teach my kids about sex and
one my um teaching my kids we have to
think when are we gonna teach our kids
about how the world is gonna be unfair
to them and you're gonna have to work
harder and you know all these things
like how do you tell your kids that and
how do you what is the best age to tell
them for me my struggle is what is the
best age to tell them how things are and
how people think of them and how they're
not thought of as equal without them not
feeling that way without them feeling
well why is that it must be true because
these are kids right something like even
with slavery when you learn about that
in school it does something to you
because you see these pictures of slaves
and chains and your that and you're like
well are we less you know or are we
inferior well why well why this and why
that and you don't understand why did
God let this happen and you know there's
all these things that go on inside of
you so for my kids I'm trying to figure
out like wood is gonna be the best age
for that where they can still stay
strong and without it chipping away at
them like it does all of us
so I didn't want them to see that
because if they saw a lot of his story
then they'd have to have to deal with
all that as well so I'm waiting to find
that balance and I'm kind of but at the
same time you don't want them to
experience something for the first time
and learn it from someone else than what
you taught right you want to be able to
Shepherd them through that yeah I mean
you know at some point I mean it's all
everything's online like they can just
spend you know forever they're not
looking for it to know but at some point
you know it's all there and I tell them
certain things like for example I'll say
well some people are mean you know and
they don't like certain people because
of a color of your skin or whatever and
you know and like they always say to me
cuz we live around here what my
daughter's like how come everyone's
vanilla or if I take her to go play
soccer she's just pretty white out yeah
yeah really so she was like really and I
said well you know what we live in an
area where there's a lot of vanilla
people Isis sometimes you go places and
there's a lot of Mexican people or a lot
of Asian people and this is just where
we live in the you go places a lot of
chocolate people so she's like oh okay
and then like when we go sign up for
sports she walks up and she's like I'm
like it's okay yeah to her is vanilla
and I'm like I didn't want to correctors
I'm like okay you know that's what she
sees as so it's just like she's starting
tall herself chocolate yeah she's like
chocolate so she's she understood well I
think that has changed it's now because
now I've heard her actually say white
and black you know they start learning
from other people but that was like a
couple years ago but it's so cute to me
there's just so you know but it but that
was me as a parent her first thought and
her first time talking about and how I
respond to it and what I say is what was
gonna stick with her
yeah so I just said that's just so man I
just she just let it go okay I said it
just depends different people live in
different areas and it's fine and
they've been they're nice girls it
doesn't matter you know she's like okay
you know so yeah that's a lot shoulder
yeah but I mean it is what it is so it's
like I believe everything happens for a
reason and just like when we talk about
my father and him not necessarily always
being there for me because what he was
doing it's like I kind of like okay
we'll all get the answers to this at
some point why things are the way they
are and why history's happened the way
that it did and you know we don't always
see the end of the tunnel mm-hmm
you know and that's when you have that
faith in knowing and then you just gotta
roll with it
you know so what do you think other than
just his innate you know humaneness like
what do you think people miss or don't
understand about your dad huh miss I
don't know in terms of cuz so many
people well life is so much more
complicated and nuanced than what you
see you know in a documentary or in a
news clip he was so that person though
like that's the thing about my dad I
would say he that's really who he was
what you saw you know my father what we
miss and people who know him miss it's
just his energy in terms of just he even
with his Parkinson's and he didn't he
didn't talk anymore he just had this
strong energy and this love you know and
that's what I've seen so many people who
just come around him and awesome to
start crying and it's they and they
don't even know why like a guru yes just
like somebody I mean who could walk into
a room and the entire room is
transformed just by his presence and
that's just something special about that
you know so that's that's what I you
know just I kind of always used to hug
him and just put my face up against his
and the way he smelled and soft hair
just like a big old sweet baby to me so
like that's what I miss about him
but I think that a lot of people just
miss this that you know you see someone
that great and wonderful that they
respect and looked up so much to and now
he's gone so I was like which watching
history unfold in front of us it's like
dang there's never gonna be another
Muhammad Ali so sad to let that go yeah
people are just different now you know
people want more of that and when I
think about why my dad was so great and
amazing
and why people are just like wow it's
just like he just believed in himself he
was a little boy from Louisville
Kentucky this thought he was the
greatest and put his all into everything
and loved himself it's like we I wish we
could just all be more like that we all
can be like Muhammad Ali and he stood up
for what he believed in he did what was
right these are basic things that we all
put on a pedestal because we can't do it
ourselves a lot of the time so it's just
like man you know just really shaped the
way that I see people and I view the
world you know and it's just like he
didn't have an entourage of people
around him he didn't go around flaunting
his money you know or put anybody down
or step on anybody to you know make
himself look better he just was a real
person you know real guy loved people
well it definitely wasn't about
no you know he understood I mean
everybody wants to have nice things you
know but it wasn't like he trusts me my
mom has told me stories that must mean
bankrupt a couple times I'm him giving
his money away right and blank checks
he'd do stupid stuff like that he was
like a kid like when it came to certain
things right is here you know and write
a blank check like he was really
gullible and naive when it came to
that's why I said we're so different
with certain things but he's just like a
big kid but yeah he understood that
having money also having the Rolex and
the the the rolls-royce would get people
to listen when you talk about
african-american community because
people are attracted to those things how
did you get what you have you know I
want that too
and then they listen so the ability to
say what you mean do it in a very poetic
compelling charismatic way and just the
honesty of it you know I think it's it
is really the more I think about it it
really you know everything that he kind
of did with the exception of being the
greatest boxer are things that we can do
and learn from and incorporate into our
own lives yeah I mean like I said
there's there's only gonna be one
Muhammad Ali but a lot of those things
we can do we can incorporate into our
own lives and I think that a lot of
people have I hear stories all the time
I mean you can imagine all the Muhammad
Ali's stories I've heard growing up when
you ask the very beginning when you like
there's got to be some things that you
love and you wish you could just forget
the things that I wish that I could that
could just go away people telling you
they're yes stop selling me like like
it's great I mean I don't want to sound
mean but I get everything that anyone
creates that you know oh it's for your
father I just want to show you this this
painting that I drew okay thank you
that's nice I've seen a million of them
as beautiful and then it's like I was
but I've been trying to get this to your
dad for years but I haven't been able to
can you help me you know it's like
anything overflowing yeah and I'm just
like I can't help you or I want to start
this line of t-shirts I can you approve
it for him oh that's the thing like they
think I can approve and I'm like I don't
have his name and like I can't approve
so it just creates extra work on my end
and for my folks you know but it's just
like that's just part
they come with it a small price to pay
right you know I'm just like but that's
the thing that's the only thing that
does annoy about being Muhammad Ali's
daughter to me it's just that kind of
stuff like really so all right well
let's land this plane I think a good way
to kind of close this it's just you know
final parting words to the person who's
listening out there who who feels stuck
you know maybe it's that guy on the
airplane or know somebody who's just you
know on a path that isn't serving them
they're not eating right they're not
taking care of themselves they're not
fulfilled in their job like what is the
you know advice or the wisdom or the
inspiration that you can impart to that
person to maybe help them like you know
look at things a little bit differently
that's a big question
I know solve that I know right I'm like
dang we're old opens up to you you know
I just really like to keep it simple and
the thing is is that God only created
one of you and I believe God doesn't
make mistakes and if you don't believe
in God you try to know there's only one
of you on this planet regardless of how
you got here okay there's only one and
you have one life to live is your life
and nobody else's you know so it's just
like really about figuring out you know
what your purpose is and that can take a
whole life life time and just trying to
be on the quest to be the best version
of yourself that's it and that's very
vague right it's very vague it's like
whether it's nutrition or mindset or
whatever it is and your relationships
your finances or whatever finding that
balance just being on the quest so I
believe in just surrounding yourself
with like-minded people people who are
on that same quest as you the tools that
you need once you do that you know cause
like it could be overwhelming but once
you find these podcasts you want to
listen to or these books or these
certain friends or these people that are
eating a certain way or that you know
exercising a certain way or whatever it
is just surround yourself with the right
people and you will start to see changes
happen that's the most important thing
you don't have to do anything else other
than that but remind you surround
yourself with the people and the tools
that you need and just make them a part
of your daily life because guess what if
you keep making that other [ __ ] a
part of your daily life that's how your
life is gonna unfold that way it's just
the way
that is right so I was like that's
pretty much it
you know because it's like you you are
gonna be the company you keep you are
gonna be the things that you surround
yourself with you are gonna be the food
that you eat so just start thinking okay
how can I start to change these things
around me this circle around me and
start making it look like the way that I
want to be or the life that I want to
have and then you're gonna be able to
pull from those things even without a
real plan other than just surrounding
yourself with it things are gonna start
to happen because those friends are
gonna say certain things to you they're
gonna they're gonna encourage you
they're going to you know challenge you
and those foods that you eat or this
thing they're gonna start giving you the
nutrition that you need the podcast that
you hear one day you might just hear one
person say one thing that you just gonna
stick with you you know what I'm saying
and it's gonna lead to something else so
it's like that's pretty much it yeah
raise the vibe across the board
yeah just raise that bar right awesome
thank you thank you so nice to talk to
you I loved it and if you want to
connect with Leila the best way to do
that Leo le comm right and you're the
real Leila what's the I am the real I am
they because there were other lollies
really yeah how is that I know it's
crazy it's an Arabic names there was a
lot of other Laila Ali so I had to make
mine real otherwise I've been Leila well
you are the real one so good talking you
thank you thank you sometimes for sure
peace
[Music]